[music]
Welcome to the show and I appreciate you
coming on today, sir. Uh this is one of
the episodes of Pale Blue Nexus and uh
we'll go with Victor for now and I
welcome and thank you and please give
yourself an introduction and uh let us
know about your practice and your
project and basically about yourself.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. First of all,
thank you for uh this invitation and uh
I know your uh channel, your podcast. I
know it quite uh well now and uh it's
you know I know about you as well. I
don't know how many people uh uh know
you but uh and your uh business history
but it's quite impressive there. So
thank you very much for this invitation.
you are former IBM, you are former uh uh
JP Morgan, you you invented uh uh ways
of business and so this is quite quite a
privilege for me. So thank you very much
for uh this talk between us uh uh today.
As I uh have already told you before
this and you have already uh suggested
as well this is a talk and so there's no
media training involved in it and so I
don't know what your uh specific uh uh
questions will be and so this is quite
uh spontaneous uh as a conversation and
so it's it's very good uh for once it's
very good to to have a a a good talk uh
um recorded talk like this one. So,
thank you very much about myself as you
asked. My name is Victor Luli and and if
you cannot uh pronounce uh Luli, that's
that's okay as well. So, it's Luli, but
it's because it's Italian, you know. I
I'm uh uh I'm Italian and I'm talking to
you uh today from S. Paulo, Brazil, uh
from one of our offices. And uh as a as
um uh uh my business activity I I am
managing partner uh of Lulia the Lulia
group that is an organization that
operates uh globally within the scopes
of investments consultancy and corporate
or large large scale uh corporate
training. So this is this is me uh
Johan.
Anything you want to know uh more about
myself and my activities, I'm here to
answer to your questions.
>> Yeah, you're you're a fascinating guy
and um one of the things I'm I'm
fascinated about is your research and
your work in
>> sort of like the neuroscience.
Um, and we talked about that on our when
we first met and I find that quite um,
interesting. You know, the mammal brain
is just very complex and we don't know
much about it. Actually, we do know a
lot about it. I just don't think it's
much into the forefront of popular sort
of uh, knowledge. Uh,
what would you think about that? Like is
that a is that a true statement? Yes,
it's it's absolutely true. Actually, I I
like to mention it because there is a
huge gap between what we know uh from a
um you know in the in the scientific
realm and scientific context uh
academically speaking. We know very much
already about uh how our brain uh works
and uh it's you know it it gained
traction from the 70s actually because
there was a a certain uh uh growth from
the uh psychological uh studies and
psychological point of view um
technology as well. Um so we actually we
know uh a lot about how our brain works
and um but you know the the the so the
public let's call it this way the naive
public um doesn't know about it you know
does not know uh how they are they are I
think the the most complex uh uh part of
who they are works and uh so this is
quite interesting and I like to mention
it because you know we we we bridged
that gap. So as a company this I can say
it uh with quite calmly you know quite
uh specifically this is one of our
biggest uh uh competitive advantages
because we we we take something that is
uh uh very very uh specific and we we
create a link between our uh brain our
mental dynamics scientifically ally
speaking to a uh business practice
actually and so we apply it in
everything we do and everything we are.
But you asking me about my uh personal
uh research and what how how I arrived
here uh uh probably so about my history
from an academic point of view. I
started studying uh uh politics
sciences. you know, I I I have uh my so
Italian origin and Italian uh uh person
from from you know I have always studied
in Italy and so as a from as a kid and
so the first approach uh Italy gives you
to to knowledge is um and from this
specific knowledge is from philosophy
actually. And so I found myself very
very very uh um let's say in love maybe
with the rhetorical aspects of knowledge
and uh so from this on I I understood as
you know during my uh growth my my
personal uh intellectual also growth I I
understood the relationship between uh
um
you know rhetoric
and uh uh behavior etc. and the use of
it uh in a in a in the most practical
way. Let's I I remember I I was
fascinated for example with uh uh the
speech of uh Maneno agre who addressed a
crowd
was during a rebellion and he addressed
the crow a crowd from a a hill in Rome
and uh he managed to to to address them
in a strategic way. And so this is I
since I remember this is this was one of
my first uh you know visions about uh
how was the relationship between uh the
rhetorical knowledge and a practical uh
uh application was. And so this is just
you know I I went to uh uh ancient
history now uh uh ancient Rome now just
for you to understand I have always
pursued this you know I have always been
in love with with uh this kind of of
knowledge this type of knowledge and so
uh my first because of this my first uh
uh field of study was uh political
sciences and began
with a uh during a a huge series of
personal events as well as as anyone uh
I decided to study uh psychology as well
and uh from psychology I went directly
to neurossychology and cognitive uh
neuroscience
and so and maybe uh um many people do
not know this But uh uh there are very
many levels of uh neuroscientific
uh knowledge and the the cognitive
neuroscientific
the cognitive uh neuroscience one is
about the way is as hierarch
hierarchically speaking is the most
advanced one.
>> Mhm. because it studies the way our
brain creates our uh mind uh uh
experience let's say and so I got
fascinated by this this uh uh kind of
study and um and when I started it I was
already a an entrepreneur you know I was
a already a businessman and uh but you
know I got I think that period that
period of time in my life was the one
where when I maybe it's just arrogantly
speaking but it was my my intelligence
speak uh uh uh in in my life you know
and so
I felt like this because it was very
stimulating for me and so I had the
privilege to to to perceive this and to
to make the most of it and um and so I I
had uh uh privileged uh access uh to
something that was my passion and and
have always been since then. And um so
the research came uh from this from this
period of time. And I think the the most
uh important line of research of that
period that that I faced and I had
access to uh was the the relation
between the brain and consciousness.
>> Mhm.
>> And so I studied it uh uh with
proper lines of uh research
um from a scientific point of view. So
using a scientical approach, we we
studied uh we studied uh um
consciousness through uh specific fMRI
uh uh protocols, MEG, MEG, MEG uh
protocols etc. So it was absolutely
interesting and uh fascinating for me
and from that
I created uh uh our lines of uh research
in the in in in through uh LUI group and
neuromarketing
uh etc. everything we do uh from that
point of view and so from this you know
I I have a a third line of study that
that came after was finance and so I had
these these three uh fields uh covered
let's say academically speaking and uh
but you know from uh neuroscience I I
applied it into neuromarketing and from
this specifically and my personal uh
business experience. I I created a a a
conceptual framework. It's a I think
it's the conceptual framework of
everything uh we do at Lully Group that
is named commercially speaking is named
u neuroinductive
practice. And so this is this is somehow
the the story and where where it comes
from. I think I wanted to explain this
in a in a the simplest way possible uh
because of you know the people uh I
don't know how much uh they could uh uh
understand the the neuroscientific
principles but the way we we we
apply it to business you know it's quite
it's quite explicit and um so this this
is this is uh what I do and um what
where this knowledge uh comes from. I I
think it's was was it clear? Was it
understandable?
>> Yeah, absolutely. And I think like my
audience and myself would be interested
in knowing how can we in your academic
background and your research and and
your experience
dealing with founders and CEOs
um and seeing how businesses play out.
What are some of the things that you
would recommend or you would see like a
lot of these business owners and CEOs
don't apply on a regular basis that you
would like them to apply? Like
are is there something that you can see
in a CEO and says, "Okay, that guy's
going to be successful. He's going to
have a successful company." Is there a
pattern there or is it largely based on
an individual by-individual basis?
You know it's there is a pattern
actually and uh if you ask me to
identify it to make it explicit to your
audience we have to start from the the
let's say conceptually speaking we have
in everything we do if we apply this uh
concepts I I'm telling you about
uh um to for example we apply to
leadership we apply to sales we apply to
negotiation etc etc. We understand that
we have elements
that we begin from. And so element for
example uh in sales is your product you
know and I think the the the most
important ability we have in from from
this specific point of view and in
general in business is the ability to
create
a a link between and a a a proper and
instrumental link between what we have
as an element and the benefits
that that element uh uh create.
Okay. So uh um this this what does it
mean that we have uh uh uh something
that by itself is just uh a a material
uh um you know element. So something
that we have also abstract one like in
leadership. So the the concept of uh
what we do etc. and to transform all
this into a a a benefit. But the benefit
and now uh we have a a um you know an
upgrade uh of what I'm telling you about
the the the benefit must be appliable to
our interlocutor
that can be a business partner that can
be uh uh you know um to whom you are
addressing your uh elevator speak speech
uh for example. It's it's your pitch uh
and um and or your customer, you know,
it's it's the same principle there. is a
principle of influence
but le let's say uh uh funnily speaking
it's uh uh um business
you know uh uh on steroids let's say
because yes it's it's funny to say but
to to tell you like this but you know
you what what is the the main uh feature
there that you understand your
interlocutor and you apply what you have
into his priorities. So I I think the
proper way to address it is to
understand that uh the characteristic
that defines successful uh business uh
uh men or business people uh like the
ones you mentioned before is this
paradigm shift. You know what you are
and what you have does not uh uh is not
that important.
But what you create from the and the
link you you can create from what you
have at your disposal and the beneficial
aspect of it to your interlocutor is
fundamental
and it is the basis for anything we do
from a business point of view and so I
identify uh uh this importance let's say
uh this successful uh pattern
from specifically this. So uh uh this
ability and uh okay it can be uh taught
it can be uh you know learned let's say
but but um you know many people don't
understand that this is the the the the
main framework from which uh start
anything you do in business and this is
also what uh uh I do is daily on a daily
basis you know the the ability I think
if if you asked me if I have superpowers
uh uh I would answer they are not super
they are very very human uh uh human
powers and
that's it you know that that's these I'm
telling you about now
there's something that I've noticed
uh call it just an instinct. But today
with the rise of AI, there is a lack of
there's there's an explosion of product.
There's an explosion of content.
And the one thing that's lessened
because of that is trust between
customer
and the vendor. So there's a lack of
trust. There's a recession in trust
happening right now and that's very
interesting. There's a lot of people
creating different types of products.
They're great products,
but there's a lack of trust happening
and it it's one of the reasons that I
produce this podcast and I've always
done authentic sort of conversations
like this. Do you notice that too as
well? Uh like have you noticed people
are a little bit more skeptical?
Customers are skeptical. Cold emails are
not as effective. Certain certain things
that you've done in the past may not
work today
is um you know I I completely agree with
your point of view actually uh it can be
uh directly linked to what uh uh I told
you before. uh I have just uh uh told
you about uh the the necessity
of the creation of this link between
what you have at your disposal and the
beneficial aspect uh uh to your
interlocutor. And so
something like this
demands a level of specificity
that is huge, that is very very high.
And so this is why AI
does not uh uh apply perfectly to the
level of specificity
you have to to gain in terms of dialogue
in terms of everything you have and the
way you propose it. And and there's a
reason why because AI first of all the
the the eye part in AI is not a proper
you know it's not intelligence
okay it's a very effective way to manage
and to uh uh elaborate data okay but
it's not an intelligence the level of
intelligence uh human uh uh humans have
is absolutely uh superior to that.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. And so this is something there's a
only who who understand uh human beings
can understand this and so properly I
mean so uh neuroscience tells you this
there there's no way it it it cannot
tell you this and so uh um the the level
of specificity in the link between who
you are and your interlocutor
cannot not be determined by a system
that works on average
or averages. Okay? And that's that's
exactly what AI uh does. you know uh uh
AI takes a huge amount of of data.
it par parameterize
uh parameterizes it
um and creates averages from it and so
you have huge huge batches of data
regarding a a topic regarding anything
you want to and from the internet and
create something that is based on a huge
average of it this absolutely makes
sense because what I see AI companies
doing large language models and such.
It's like they're trying to put more
data and specificity inside their models
in order to mimic the the average level
of intelligence that that goes up. But I
don't think
>> it's the contrary.
>> Yeah, it is the contrary because it's
things are always shifting and things
are always moving. There's different
things in the world that would shift.
there's uh narratives that will change
and it's hard to keep up with that.
Yeah.
>> Yes. Actually uh you know if you use uh
uh artificial intelligence as a as a
specific tool I mean you have a
framework you have a a paradigm
that you want to uh work upon through
artificial intelligence. Okay, let's
see. For example, in Formula 1, I talk
uh to uh Formula 1 uh managers, for
example, and uh the way they use
artificial intelligence is through uh
something they that they uh uh start
from that is theirs that's you know
that's that's specifically uh determined
by them and use AI as a tool. It's just
an example, you know, because uh um
Formula 1, for example, as as any
business uh uh is determined by the
level of of efficiency uh uh of what
they do. But if you if you have a
company and you work on huge amounts of
of data,
you cannot expect uh uh but to to create
uh averages. And so the the the the
moment you address to a customer or to
you know a business partner etc is based
on average. And so this is this is quite
uh uh dangerous from a specificity and
uh uh uh efficiency point of view that
business demands.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. And absolutely I I think there is
a a level of specificity that it's
always changing
and it's getting harder and harder to
persuade and
>> persuasion is is is ahead of the curve
when it comes to maybe they should come
up with artificial persuasion. I don't
think it can happen
>> you know uh uh just okay let's let's
make an example about this specifically
you start from a knowledge that is based
for example marketing
>> okay you start from something that
conceptually speaking is the uh uh
unique selling proposal
okay that is something that you and only
you uh can deliver
okay to the public to the to your market
etc and you uh uh are aware of it and
you use it etc strategically
in your sales use etc etc the way you
address uh your public now you have this
and every founder today I know that uses
something that that is merely informatic
uh says we use artificial intelligence
to do this this this this everyone one
is telling me the same. So how do I
perceive
your uniqueness? How how do I perceive
your unique selling proposal there?
Okay, so we have a proprietary
uh uh way of addressing AI. Okay, this
is another uh uh way to address it and
this is proper but you know uh uh um not
not many uh do this uh these days and
and it's also it's always the same
speech now.
>> Yeah,
>> this is wrong. This is specifically
wrong. No, we started from something
that was uh specifically determined
that is the the the the marketing uh um
concept unique selling proposal etc. And
you come today uh with your pitch and
then you you put your effort on etc and
say something that every everybody is
saying. So this is just wrong you know.
So what do you have uh uh of uniquely uh
determined and what is the effect
that this uh uniqueness you have on what
is the effect of this to you know your
public to your market etc. And and so
this is this is the the the simple basis
you know of business but we are losing
it somehow because of the averages
that we are creating. So and more and
more and this will uh become
uh um more specific average. So it's it
seems to me like the business community,
the founder community, the
entrepreneurial community is undergoing
a shift from
hey I can make a web page. No well now
everyone can make a web page. There's
just a level of averess that has sort of
up the bar. So now everybody needs to go
above that and to the next level of
>> let's raise the bar right in terms of
your unique selling proposition.
>> But I mean it has always been like this
but now today you have an explosion of
this but it has always been like this.
Why? Because it's called uh uh
competitiveness.
Yeah.
>> You know uh uh you have to set the bar
higher than your competitor.
But you have to understand what your
competitor is and you have to understand
as well. You have to comp to understand
what you have of you know your
uniqueness
and the paradigm shift I was telling you
about uh the the beneficial aspect of it
precisely
for your interlocutor. Interruptor can
be for example an investor that you are
talking to during a pitch or uh your
large market etc etc. So the more
precise you have this clear in your
mind,
the more uh uh you can gain uh um
anything you you desire from it, you
know. And uh so now the behavioral part
the behavioral aspect of it is mainly
the ability to determine to determine
uh who your interrogator are and the way
he moves what are his uh what his pre
priorities are etc etc etc. So just for
you to understand this is quite specific
and it must be
so now just you know everybody is doing
uh something they are not getting
specific uh and uh of about what they're
doing and they are not getting specific
of the bene the benefits that they are
promoting and they are not being
specific on about the the their
interlocator the definition of it. So,
we have more tools at your uh at our uh
disposal,
but you are you're not using the proper
way, you know. So, we have to understand
this because you cannot be blind on it.
I I just had a image in my head. I don't
know if F1 is the is the uh analogy
here, but maybe it's NASCAR, but that
everybody has the same engine in the
car. It's just the driver now needs to
know uh where to steer if it's a not a a
straightforward track, but the track is
open and everybody has the same power in
a way with these models.
>> Yes, it it it does not apply to Formula
1 specifically, but yes, your example is
correct, you know. So what uh uh what
makes you uh different
you know and so this is the this is uh
uh the starting point of of any business
and uh so we are losing it somehow and I
perceive it also uh uh I I you know I
talk uh to many people from different uh
uh perspectives and in different I have
three operations uh um uh going on uh
through Luri group. And so we we have
different ways to approach each one of
them and uh each each uh demand uh of
those. And so uh we understand this from
many points of view and from each one of
these points of view we perceive the
exact uh same thing. So you have to go
very very high in in terms of uh
specificity uh um efficiency uh demand
to understand that people are acting the
proper way from this point of view and
the the the formula one example is
exactly this you know so how do you uh
turn yourself to be uh uh relevant and
they they use it they use their tools
in the proper way. If I if you know just
imagine if they didn't
>> Yeah.
>> it would lose everything. And so you
have founders, you have entrepreneurs
etc. that you know you you must
understand that if you don't do it the
proper way, you're just losing money and
possibilities.
That is the the main the main reason why
you should be getting up in the morning.
create possibilities, create uh uh
things, etc. Please.
>> I think it's you're absolutely right.
It's like we have such great tools now
and a lot of people don't know what to
build. They don't know where to steer.
They don't know what to focus on. And I
think it's a it's an interesting time
that even myself, it's like I can build
so many things. I can open up my my dev
tools and they're quite powerful and
amazing. It's just what do you want to
build? What do you what what do you
want? Where's the unique selling
proposition? Where's the value that's
create being created? Where's the
benefits that are being created? And I
guess you're seeing this on a larger
level. But the one uh thing I'm also
interested in is there are organizations
that are a lot slower to move.
There are huge organizations that are
possibly being disrupted. Um, and
acquisitions
are happening quite fast because big
organizations are seeing smaller
organizations meet that product market
fit
>> quite quickly and they're just let let's
bring you in house type of thing, right?
Like are you seeing a lot of that?
>> Yes. uh um you know about speed. Yes,
everything is moving uh quite faster and
you have uh finance that is uh moving
quite fast as well and um you have more
access nowadays and uh you you have you
know when you start to operate
uh bigger and bigger you start to
operate globally.
>> Mhm. And so you have a global scope and
in everything you do. It's not
international anymore. You know, you
have a a global scope. We we we work in
with uh 28 countries uh today. And so we
have different cultures. We have uh
different ways of approaching things
etc. And you know it's it's it's the way
uh things are moving now. And so um
you you must be more efficient.
>> So you must be more competitive in
anything you do and you must use your
tools in the most proper uh way possible
you know that's just it you know so you
have bigger companies etc. Yes, you have
damn uh uh fagositating uh eating uh um
but but it has always been like this.
But now we have more access and more
visibility uh to these uh dynamic to
these uh dynamics. And uh also just for
you to understand a a perspective of
ours and how do we manage it and again
it starts from uh neuroscience as well.
No, because one of uh the assumptions
let's say the premises uh that we have
from a neuroscientific uh uh point of
view
uh is conceptually speaking is uh each
uh each brain works the same way. So we
do not consider uh the person from as
culturally determined but biologically
determined.
And so just just uh um we we we start
from the origins of behavior of anyone
uh we are uh talking to. And so this is
a huge advant advantage also
scientifically speaking uh is a huge
advantage uh for our businesses and uh
for each and every uh uh dynamic uh we
operate in and we create in a in a in
this scale let's say the global scale as
well. So this is a huge advantage. And
so
if I uh should if I could evaluate our
competitiveness, our competitive
advantage
inside this scale say it's working. You
know, for this uh specific point of
view,
I've heard and with the people I'm
talking to, AI is one technology.
There are other technologies that AI
will enable but they are as
I guess transforming as AI. You you talk
about robotics. You talk about quantum
and quantum computing.
These are all coming around at the same
time. Has there ever been a time like
this in history? Like is this
>> what what is the next 10 years going to
look like? And which of those
technologies are you excited about?
>> Uh uh you know Johan uh we have this uh
I don't want to to say uh uh it is an
illusion let's say but let's remember
that uh men humankind started to fly
and just a few years later he went to
the moon.
It's it's it's it's not that far, you
know. It's we're talking about uh uh not
that many years. Uh uh so things have
always moved very very fast in in
everything uh uh we made for just for
you uh uh to to understand my point of
view. you had uh illuminism
that gave us access to the human being
as biologically determined
and so from from it's not uh uh far from
from uh where we are now. So just
imagine what what it uh represented
from illuminism to uh uh our present
day. And so this is a huge explosion of
knowledge from that because of you know
religion and the divine access to human
beings etc. So before that we couldn't
access uh to human beings as as
biologically determined. It's just an
example. So uh uh from that period of
time to today we have a uh we are
talking about neuromarketing now between
us you know we are talking about the the
the specificity of [snorts] uh brain
activity and so from this specifically
from this you ask me about uh the future
and maybe priorities from a a business
point of view you know you have all the
the the biological
uh advances. Okay. But uh you know just
imagine what uh uh can represent
the union between everything we know
from a neuroscientific point of view and
robotics and everything is informatic.
So
you know uh the first uh uh the first
things uh come to my mind is BMI so
brain machine interface.
Okay. So this is something we have uh uh
invested in uh since its its inception
since its beginning and we are uh uh
quite pioneers in that just you know so
this is something I believe in uh very
very much and I am actually I am
available to to put my money in it you
know like like I have already uh done
and been doing uh uh since you know it's
years already and so and so just imagine
what uh
you know what future will become
you know putting together in the same uh
batch
biological
uh advancement
uh AI and brain machine interfaces. So
just just imagine that what can become
for
you know uh military
u efficiency in in business, efficiency
in knowledge etc etc. So access to
knowledge. So we we will have an
exponential uh growth uh from this point
of view also. This is a a huge
advancement in um cognition,
>> right? Okay. And uh from many points of
view and also the therapeutic
uh uh uh of it, you know, the
therapeutical approach of it, what can
become?
So what you're saying is that LLMs by
themselves
and is is is not the way but the com
combination between the human brain
and this is what's going to cause an
exponential growth in things and and how
far do you see that? Like I already
carry my smartphone. Uh people they're
tied to their smartphone. Um, and but
you're saying there's a link there that
it can be a lot faster and more
efficient with a human uh brain machine
interface.
How how and you're investing into it.
So, how tight do you see that
integration being and what are your
thoughts on that and predictions about
that?
>> Okay. uh um how tight 100%. Just imagine
I I think if if I have to to you are
asking me something that is very
difficult to determine of course so uh
uh we don't have our we can imagine how
things will be okay and um if you know
asking me to imagine it I think uh every
one of us will have an interface applied
to our brains okay because it will be
the the the new normal
the new regular uh way of uh living just
like our smartphone, you know, because
you will reach a level from from uh
example from
uh um
you know operational point of view, from
a u medical point of view etc etc. You
will have the the the the most advanced
piece of matter we know about in the
universe that is our brain
applied to the most advanced
technology we have at your at our
disposal. Now there is AI and machine
learning uh uh context of of uh uh
operating etc. And so we have the union
of this. I think in this union resides
our future
from any point of view diagnosis uh um
you know oper anything is operation
because we we have to understand that uh
um you have millions of years of
evolution that
guided us and make us be what we are.
And we have uh uh our nervous systems
that are the most advanced uh part of of
what we are and our brain is uh the most
advanced part of a new nervous system.
Okay. And so this is uh I I think it's
inevitable to see the union of of this
all and the the the
you know the the growth of our cognitive
ability because of it and as as anything
that comes to us at at our disposal you
have uh uh you have to choose how let's
say choose how to use it. Okay. if use
it as a tool in order to to improve what
you are and what you do etc. just like
normal regular AI now. And the the the
most smart the smartest uh way to to to
use it just like it was and it is the
internet and everything we have. I can
use YouTube
to see something very very use as as as
your podcast for example. I can choose
to see it or I can choose uh uh not to
to you know I don't mean no lack of
disrespect
about it but I can see so I can choose
to see uh a duck you know uh uh you know
just circling around you know a pot you
know you can choose it let's say you can
choose it but today I choose to uh uh
watch something very useful and of the
highest level possible like your podcast
and specifically our interview of
course. [laughter]
Is there a downside to human machine
interaction? Yes. Yes. Of course. as any
uh technology uh the manipulative side
of it you know because
that that's where uh regulation reside I
see okay and so just like the internet
as I told you if if you you know
you if you use these tools
or everything we have at at our disposal
proposal in a manipulative way it
becomes negative for humankind.
Okay. But so it's it's something ethical
here that we have to to address. I can
use it just like neuroscience just like
everything we have at our disposal. You
can uh use it in a destructive way and
you can use it in a constructive way.
Okay. So everything we are and so if if
you apply greed to this for example it
depends greed for money
>> it's one thing greed for knowledge
let's let's uh uh let's accept it you
know and uh just it's not it's not
called greed but just for you to
understand uh uh the the the hunger for
uh beautiful things the hunger for uh um
you know possibilities etc knowledge
etc. And so there are uh uh downsizes of
it and this is a huge one for example
>> uh it's a it's like it seems like this
may be the conversation that happens in
the next 5 to 10 years. It's like
>> where does this go? And it's going to
play out you know day by day and and
month by month and quarter by quarter.
Uh we are still very
uh to your point very greed driven very
profit driven which is a good thing. Um
however we do need to sort of balance
that out with the ethical side of things
and uh
>> yes yes is anything uh from my point of
view is is anything Johan. So you have
uh Europe now nowadays
uh there are willing to that is Europe
as a government is willing to regulate
what we do. you have Australia that is
uh preventing uh the the the youngest to
access for example uh social media et
and so you have different realities uh
nowadays or in terms of how you uh uh
approach these new uh frontiers you know
and um so it's it's it's
the way things go. Now how do I do
there? There is one premise here that is
very very important and that is
um you know ethically speaking
uh we have human beings that are quite
fragile from a cognitive point of view.
Okay. And so uh we have extreme
difficulties
between our present action and our
long-term goals. This is one of the
fundamentals, one of the premises we
have at our disposal. For example, uh in
in behavioral economics, the reason why
behavioral economics are very important
nowadays,
extremely important. So and this is the
basis of of what we do uh as well and
basis of successes uh u you have to be
uh very clear about it. You have to uh
reach a certain level of clarity between
your present action and your long-term
uh goal. And so this is this requires an
enormous effort from a cognitive point
of view, you know. And so um yes we are
facing this but with a with um you know
with quite a a fragile human being there
that is being approached by these
technologies. So this is this is
something to to look at very very uh in
in a robust act ethic ethical uh uh um
approach.
You know, I we've already hit 50 minutes
and it's fascinating that it time went
that fast, but um I think I love your
web page. It's it's the it's a brain and
it's gold
>> and it's it's just
>> um Thank you very much for it.
>> Yeah, it it really shows what you feel
about the human brain and how important
it is. And that's the one takeaway I
would I I want to take from this
interview for myself is that there is so
much power there in our brain. It's a
golden device and it's to be cherished
and it's to be used uh there is a lot of
potential in it, right? And I think
that's
>> Yeah. Where can we keep up with you,
Victor? And uh where can we know more
about uh what you're up to?
>> You know, just first step would be ask
me just just everything is is open.
uh you know we are expanding a lot and
um we are working with very strictly
with uh the Middle East specifically we
are embracing for example vision 2030 in
Saudi Arabia so we are making you are
making it we are making it ours and um
so it's everything we do is long-termed
and um from also from a a legacy point
of view. So it's very important for us
to understand uh uh that everything we
do means legacy as well because of the
origin of our capital. This family
capital because of uh uh you know the
scientific approach of what we do and
actually
this is we are moving uh fast. We are
always uh willing to uh follow
uh the the the the all the possibilities
that that we have at our uh disposal
from uh technologies
uh from you know many points of view
from finance etc point of view and so
and also we have many many uh
possibilities nowadays with uh gene
therapy for therapy for example and uh
from, you know, the biological aspects
of uh uh what we are and [snorts]
um you know
everything that that uh biology itself
can offer us and uh something that that
we are uh approaching uh these days is
uh a company it it it can be public.
because since you asked me about it,
it's EVIS the the name of the company
and we are already discussing we are
very very impressed by what they are
achieving
they they you know
it's it's it's interesting because we
are talking about uh uh RNA
and so we have their proprietary
platform form to load ex extracellular
vesicles the are the the natural
messengers of the bay of the of our
bodies and they are able to load these
extracellular vesicles with RNAs
which is a uh something extremely
difficult that that they managed to to
achieve and this is also uh something
that I uh I am following in very very uh
strictly and very very uh with
proximity, you know, because we think
this is this is something that that has
a an immense and very very um
potential future there. So this is only
an example of course but it's a valid
one and also it it reveals
from a financial and investment point of
view what means all that legacy and
long-term vision that we have. It's not
only real estate for example real estate
vision 2030 is it is something that it's
immense as an approach and it's it's for
long term because of the size of it.
Okay. And uh but
from relationship between technology
and AI and brains etc. as we discussed
before we have BMI we have brain machine
interfaces and also why not from a
specifically uh determined biological
approach to life so biotechnology etc.
we have this kind of of examples. So
from the projects to brains to uh
uh biology itself etc. And the example
is is is evis
that we are uh uh approaching right now.
So this is quite a a interesting uh
period of of our uh time for us I mean
for our company. Yeah. I I bet it's it's
every every investor and capital
allocator is just like very excited
right now. I think like they they see a
potential to
>> shape the future which is what this
podcast discusses as well. I wanted to
say thank you Victor for coming on the
show. It's been quite fascinating and
this will be clipped up and delivered to
the my mass audiences and it across all
channels and I just wanted to say thank
you for taking the time today uh and
coming on and explaining
>> you know I I loved the possibility and
the perspective of uh this interview
since I knew you for the first time.
Well, it's it's uh for me it's it was
very interesting. You delivered uh
absolutely that interest that I that I
had perceived from the first time
talking to you and with you and uh so it
was a privilege for me not just you know
not because uh many people will will see
it etc. Not just that you know but
because I I found it very interesting
and I thank you for that. Absolutely.
So, it was my uh privilege for it.
>> Thank you so much for saying that.